even as anarchists mindlessly tear up
american cities while attacking police
and innocent bystanders
we republicans do recognize those who
work in good faith
towards peace justice and equality
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
took the mic at the republican national
convention on tuesday night
and his speech has cardi b feeling some
type of way
listen let me tell you guys here's what
went down
cameron is the first black attorney
general in the state
and is responsible for investigating the
killing of brianna taylor
a 26 year old emt who was fatally shot
in her own home
by louisville kentucky metro police
earlier this year
her death sparked protests worldwide and
still
no arrests have been made but cameron
only briefly mentioned taylor during his
nearly
seven minute address in fact
it was general dwight eisenhower a
future republican president
who said democracy is a system that
recognizes
the equality of humans before the law
whether you are the family of brianna
taylor or david dorn
these are the ideals that will heal our
nation's wounds
yep that was it and cardi she wasn't
feeling it
shortly after he delivered his speech
the rapper hit up
instagram to slam the politician writing
quote
this is such a slap in the face noting
that he didn't make mention of arresting
the cops who were responsible for her
death
quote here you are at the podium of the
republican conventions talking about
justice
america and all this [ __ ] you so
blinded by your masters
that you don't even notice that they're
using you as a pawn to trigger your own
kind
cardi wrapped up her post writing never
would they ever had you up there if you
wasn't in charge of brianna taylor case
but she isn't the only celeb doing her
part to keep the fight for justice alive
in july real housewives of atlanta star
portia williams was arrested alongside
87 other protesters
who had gathered outside of cameron's
[Applause]
[Music]
home
she was arrested again on tuesday during
a peaceful protest in louisville in
honor of taylor
we love you everybody porsha was charged
with obstructing a highway
and disorderly conduct in the second
degree i
need to be with my people with our
allies
side by side and fighting for real
change for the other families who have
been victims of police brutality and get
this
for the first time in 20 years oprah
winfrey stepped away from the cover of
her magazine to instead
feature taylor would you be content to
hear
five months later there's an
investigation
and that no one has been held
accountable for shooting
your innocent daughter multiple times
and letting her life bleed out she also
paid for dozens of billboards around
louisville
in an effort to amplify taylor's story
and
seek justice for her death these 26
billboards
won for every year of brianna's life
are my offering my form of protest we
cannot be silent we have to use whatever
megaphone we have
to cry for justice